[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Hi
I'm Priyanka Vergadia,
and thanks for tuning in
to Deconstructing Chatbots.
Today's episode
is a special one,
because I have invited Anu
Srivastava from our Cloud ML
team.
Hey Anu, how are you?
ANU SRIVASTAVA: I'm doing great.
I'm really excited
to be here and share
some things about integrating
Google Chat with Dialogflow.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, awesome.
Let's dive in.
We know that Dialogflow is a
natural language understanding
platform that helps us
design and integrate
conversational experiences
for mobile, web, phone,
and lots of other things.
And Google Chat is an
intelligent messaging app
within G-Suite, built
for teams to make
it easy to have one or more
thread of communications
in a virtual room.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Right.
So it also has a third-party
platform, an SDK,
for bot integrations.
And that's what I'm excited to
be talking to you about today.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well, cool.
What are some of the benefits
of bots in Google Chat?
ANU SRIVASTAVA:
So if I'm a user,
I don't really want to have to
install an app for every task
that I have to do.
So installing apps
for mobile or desktop,
you can just do some of your
workflows and automations
in a chat room by direct
messaging a bot with an app
mention to get started.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Right.
So if I wanted to chat with
you, normally when I chat,
I would just say @Anu and
your name would pop up
and then I would start typing
whatever I want to ask you.
So it seems like that's
exactly what you do with bots.
You just type @ the
name of the bot.
And if you don't
remember the name,
it will just populate
a list of names
and then you can select
from it, which is awesome.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Yeah.
So to make it easy
with bots, you
can kind of treat bots as you
would humans in the chat room.
And then now you have this
team memory in the chat.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Awesome.
So as a developer, how do
I get started in setting up
bots in Google Chat?
ANU SRIVASTAVA: So
let's take an example.
Today we'll use a use case
that comes from our sales team.
Our story actually
starts in a sheet.
Google is a large
company and it's
hard to know who the right
person is to contact.
Our sales accounts are
grouped into clusters
and each cluster has accounts.
And then within
those accounts, we
have account managers
and engineers
that specialize in skills
like security and networking.
So it gets really
complicated to figure out
who the right person is to ping
when you get a question, even
within your department.
So we have lots of
spreadsheets like this
used by the sales team.
I have a copy of
one of these sheets
from one of the European teams.
I have scrapped out their
names and test accounts.
This is test data.
And instead of actual
customers listed,
we're using some
Google products.
But the setup of the
sheet is the exact same.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Currently,
say if I'm a sales rep
and I have a
question about who is
responsible for this particular
piece of information.
I would come to this sheet and
look for my answers, right?
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Right.
So for example, let's say
I get a question like,
who can advise on security
best practices for the YouTube
account?
First, I would want to find
the engineer in that cluster
and then figure out
who is on security.
Or, maybe I actually need
to connect to someone
who knows the account info.
So I would connect to
the account manager.
Let's say I need
networking for analytics.
Then I would check here.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, this works fine.
But if you're on the
go and you're just
looking for this
information, you really
don't want to look
for a sheet URL
and then try and find that
information within it,
because that can be too hard.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Right.
And it would be
great if I could just
get this information in chat.
Most likely, what
I'm going to do
next is open a chat tab to talk
to whoever I find in the sheet.
And that's where
this bot comes in.
I don't want to have to open
a new tab and wait for it
to load.
Reducing context switching
is a key point in using bots.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Right,
and then slow Chrome tabs
when I have 1,000 of them open.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Right.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
That would be cool,
but this sheet looks
pretty complicated.
How are we going to be able to
extract all this information
into things that we need?
ANU SRIVASTAVA:
I'm glad you asked.
So we'll actually be
using the Sheets API.
And you're right, this
is pretty complicated.
It's designed for
human consumption.
It's not really a database.
But we can work around that.
So to answer a query,
we need to know
three pieces of information.
Number one, the account name,
so we can't get the cluster.
Number two, the specialty.
And last but not
least, the role type.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Oh, I
see where this is going.
Usually when you create
bots, or chat applications,
you need the pieces
of information
that act as your input.
So in this case, these
three pieces of information
become your input to the bot.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Exactly.
So I could write a basic
bot that expects these three
inputs in a certain
order, but it would be
unnatural and difficult to use.
As a user, I'd have to
remember the exact order
and I'd always have to spell
everything right, which
I definitely don't do.
And we know that
with technology,
if it's too hard to use,
people aren't going to use it.
So this is where
Dialogflow comes in.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yep.
And that is what Dialogflow
is great at doing,
because it's powered with
natural language understanding.
And it helps understand
normal human words.
And it's OK to make mistakes.
It's OK to ask not
in order sometimes,
and it would still be able to
understand what you're saying.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Yes.
So, I'm going to show
this to you in reverse.
Let's take a look at
the bot, and then we'll
break it down on
how we built it.
So let's do a
couple test queries.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Say
I want to know who is
on Gmail for data management.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Great.
And now we see the
follow-up intent,
because you need one more
piece of information.
Awesome.
So now let's actually
break it down.
First, we need to
define the entities,
then we'll make the
intents, and then
we'll implement fulfillment
to make this all work.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, if you've
watched previous
episodes of this series,
these concepts
should be familiar.
But if not, then the
playlist is linked below.
Go check them out.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Step one,
defining the entities.
Let's look at the
specialties that we
have in this table, which will
group together similar words.
I've defined the synonyms
and enabled fuzzy matching
to be generous with the input.
Meaning, if I make a typo,
which I definitely will,
it will still connect
to the same entity.
The synonyms are really key
to making the system robust.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Right.
And say in this case, if
you look down into G-Suite,
we can see that they are
all grouped together,
like Docs and Gmail.
So now let's define the intents.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: The
intent is a category
of what the user is asking
for, their intentions.
So you always want to
have a welcome intent.
And it's best practice
to give the user
some instructions on how
to interact with your bot.
So when I first add
the bot to this room,
this is where the
response comes from.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
And then now we
want to know what happens
with those intents,
or when those intents
are triggered.
So, the actions and the
parameters for those intents.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Right.
So we've defined the
intent lookup Googler.
So this is where all
the good stuff goes.
Let's go ahead and put those
entities into this intent.
They are all required for
this intent to be fulfilled.
If a user forgets one of
them, I define a prompt
to get it from the
user, as we saw earlier.
So if they forget a
piece of information,
they'll see this
prompting question.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Got it.
In our example use case,
they forgot the account,
so they see the question to
input the account information.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Yep.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Cool.
Different people
talk differently,
so they will ask the
question in a different way.
How do I train the bot so
that all these examples
are incorporated?
ANU SRIVASTAVA: So that's
where step four comes in,
training phrases.
In my opinion, this
is the fun part.
Dialogflow uses a
pre-trained model,
but we can add our own specific
questions for this bot.
So I've added these
as training data,
and you can see that it'll
detect the parameters I
have just told it about.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So once
we put all that information
into the training phrases,
how do we actually
know that it's all working?
How can we test this?
ANU SRIVASTAVA:
So in the console,
you can actually test
it out exactly how it
would work on Google Assistant.
So I know that we're
building ours for G-Suite,
but I will touch on how you can
support multiple platforms just
right out of the box in a bit.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Now,
let's see how this actually
connects to the back end.
In this case, the Sheets API.
We would have to go
and create a webhook.
How do we do that?
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Let
me just go ahead
and show you step five,
the fulfillment code.
So we can look at
this Node.js code,
which is using those
libraries we're talking about.
So like the Sheets
API, the chat API,
all of these in
the package, which
has all of these libraries.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Now, how can we
add the images and buttons
and other types of widgets
if they are needed for
the interaction to work?
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Yeah, this is
how we make it really rich.
We just construct
these with JSON
how we want the
chat cards to look
and then push it to
the Dialogflow agent.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
We want to make
this work with Google Chat.
So how do we make
that integration?
ANU SRIVASTAVA: So here in
the integration section,
chat is actually
enabled by default.
But let's say I wanted it to
work with multiple platforms.
I could just select some of the
other boxes in this section.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
So it's that simple.
It was really just a
click of the button
to actually enable it, once
we got the bot to work.
This has been awesome, Anu.
Thank you so much for
showing how it's done.
For anyone who wants
to try this out,
Anu has the code up on GitHub,
which we have linked below.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: And if you'd
like to dive deeper, or have
any questions, leave us
a comment or tweet at us.
ANU AND PRIYANKA: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]